this crater hints at the size of the
explosion in western ghana the blast
happened on thursday when a truck
collided with a motorbike the truck was
carrying explosives to a gold mine the
result was shocking as filmed by
eyewitnesses
dozens of homes were destroyed in this
village near the town of bogoso 300
kilometers west of the capital accra
on friday morning ghana's vice president
muhammadu buhari visited a shelter as
food age started to arrive he assured
the community his government would help
them recover and rebuild
the government is going to be
responsible fully
fully for all their medical bills and
everything else the ghanaian government
says it's investigating the explosion
eyewitnesses say after the collision the
truck driver jumped out of the vehicle
which was on fire and shouted at people
to stay away a police spokesperson has
said the truck did have a police escort
who also helped alert people but with so
many dead ghanaians are doubtless
wondering how this could have happened
nadine barber al jazeera